women will do anything for attention
anything and this is just part of female
nature we attention is to women as to as
Sexes to men women want to be beautiful
men want to have sex okay and the
problem is we have women that again have
had unlimited attention from the time we
were like 12 years old and we go into
the world and now we are addicted to
this attention and that is why you see
women doing crazier and crazier and
crazier things for attention especially
once our attention starts to go with the
dreaded wall now the wall is really the
age between
28 27 28 and like 35 roughly whenever
the woman's looks start to kind of go
um and she realizes she can't get the
attention she used to get and
um that's when you see chicks going real
crazy
really insane yeah just like absolutely
nuts because they realize they've had
Britney Spears level of attention from
the time they're 12 years old to now
it's kind of starting to go and these
sisters really proved it I don't know
what age they were but they're Ukrainian
sisters were arrested for twerking on
the graves of Fallen Soldiers
they are facing uh five years in prison
so these chicks
twerked on the graves of Fallen Soldiers
and guys unfortunately this is not the
first time I've seen something like this
I have seen when I have seen women
working at funerals I have seen women
um twerking on a casket I have like
women will use our sexuality for
political reasons
um or just for stupid reasons like this
um I don't know why on Earth you would I
don't know why on Earth you would go and
work
on the graves
of soldiers that fought for their
country it's like the audacity women and
that's a thing like
women it's just kind of how we are this
is probably the product of either a weak
father or a single mother because women
from stable two-parent homes where the
dad leads don't typically have this
problem or maybe they've been addicted
to attention from the time they were
like 12 years old and it's actually
absolutely disgusting I and I hope they
do spend five years in prison because
women do this stuff all the time and
there's never a consequence and until
women start to have consequences for
their actions I don't see us ever
changing I I think if you if you let a
kid do whatever they want they'll just
keep doing whatever they want until
there's a punishment I I say give them
the five years because
not only did they twerk on the graves
they filmed it
like this is uh so crazy so Twitter has
responded and they said Tick Tock has
ruined this generation yeah he's right
women have been addicted to attention
from the time they're 12. what else what
what were they twerking with by the way
I see no behind though
all right you didn't have to
burn why are you
like why are you why are you
what whatever all right twerking gone
wrong twerk in prison they most
certainly deserve it such a disrespect
to Fallen Hero I I agree especially men
that are fighting for our country
they're fighting for our country
and you have the audacity to twerk on
their like it's just ridiculous